So, as I mentioned in
sort of a conventional or
traditional tracking approach,
what you do is you build a model
before something starts moving, right?
So you might cut out a patch,
find a contour,
some method of describing the object.
And then you do one of,
remember we talked about optic flow
where you essentially connect the dots.
You do patch tracking with particles,
which if you're in the OMS class,
you did as a problem set.
Or you might even solve some
interesting, complicated,
optimization problem.
And then you somehow try to
incorporate some invariance.
So you might use edges, because you
know that those don't change a lot
depending upon how the illumination
changes, let's say, all right?
But the problem is, if I'm going to
track an object over an extended period
of time, the object and
the environment tend to change.
And what I would like to do is I would
like to not just track the object but
in some sense track the changes,
incorporate the changes
slowly as the object moves.
So some work that we're
going to talk about and
these are some slides taken from,
from Yang.
Who showed a piece,
who did a piece of work that I'll talk
about along with Ross and Edal they
took some inspiration from two places.
First of all Michael Black and
Allen Jepson way back in 1996 did
something called Eigen tracking, so
you guys know all about Eigen faces.
Well, Eigen tracking was the same
idea but the idea is so, here we have
Coca Cola cans and here we have these
Eigen images, up this one's a 7 Up can.
How did that get in there?
Okay, we have Eigen images of
these different objects and
the idea was we're going to track
this thing by finding the places
we can represent well by
using those Eigen images.
But one of the cool things they did was,
they said, you know ,remember what
didn't work so well in eigen analysis,
the eigen face, was the alignment?
Things had to be aligned perfectly?
Well, suppose we decompose
the problem into the geometric part.
That is, how is my object moving,
maybe rotating,
scaling, to what does it look like.
Now we've already seen this, right?
When we were doing the good
features to track, we talked a bit.
In fact, there was an image of of
a speed limit sign getting bigger and
bigger and it was being tracked and
the idea was it's the same image patch,
it just deforms.
Well, there they were using
a single image patch.
In the eigen tracking, the idea was that
we're going to look for a deformation.
So could be affine,
could be otherwise, where we got,
where we have remote translation,
rotation, scaling maybe even shearing.
But now instead of just
taking a single patch,
we actually have a set of eigen
vectors that describe the coke can.
So for example, maybe if I rotate
the coke can a little bit or maybe some,
some other change, I could represent
all those different appearances.
When they did it, it was done in sort of
a non linear optimization way and they,
but more importantly they
took a fixed basis set.
So it took a whole bunch of images
of coke cans, created a basis set,
said that's our Coca Cola basis set.
So we're going to need to do
some improvement on that.
The other inspiration here is also
something that we've covered,
which was particle filtering.
Remember Isard and Blake,
they instead of having a single
proposal the idea is that you'd
have a bunch of particles and
each particle would represent
a possible location.
And that allowed us to handle sort
of non parametric densities, right?
Use the sampling based approach and
there what they were using
were like contours, right?
And they would propagate this over time,
they would,
they would move the particles forward.